il y à 25 ans un tragique accident de
voiture emportée celle que tout le monde
appelait la princesse du peuple la
disparition tragique et brutale de lady
diana qui est morte à paris dans un
accident de voiture la voiture roulait à
vive allure sans doute pour tenter
d'échapper aux paparazzis son nom lady
diana ancienne épouse du prince charles
est membre éternel de la famille royale
ce soir du 30 août 1987 alors que son
chauffeur tente d'échapper à une horde
de paparazzi dans paris sa voiture a
violemment percuté un mur sous le pont
de l'alma cet amas de ferraille témoigne
de la violence de l'accident les
passants ont vu la voiture percutée un
ping et à une vitesse d'au moins 150 km
heure
mercredi ils étaient des milliers à lui
rendre hommage à travers la planète
d'abord à paris au pied de la flamme de
la liberté c'est touchant de voir encore
un tas de gens
mais aussi au royaume uni à londres où
de nombreux britanniques se sont
rassemblés devant son ancienne résidence
de kesington palace j'ai apporté des
fleurs ce petit collage et un poème
pas de commémoration officielle de la
part de la famille royale mais ses deux
fils william et harry ont tenu à lui
rendre hommage séparément
ce soir thomas pernette journaliste et
auteur spécialiste de la royauté et on
revient avec nous sur les 25 ans de la
mort de lady di dans notre interview
people de la semaine
c'est lé 25 ans
des lady di tota fernet de point de vue
est avec nous alors c'est un expert je
peux vous dire que chez norauto mais
pourquoi pourquoi apport d'actions
nature pour laval olalala savait pas
compris
pourquoi d'abord déjà 25 ans après est
ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle a toujours la
même image cette image de princesse des
coeurs princesse lice alors oui à la
fois elle est toujours ce mythe est
d'ailleurs on se souvient tous où on
était quand on a appris la mort de diana
roi pour ceux qui étaient nés est assez
grand pour s'en souvenir oui je sais que
la prod m'a dit que vous n'étiez pas né
ce moment là tu sais très gentil
absolument rien ne bouge
mais oui alors le mythe a quand même
évolué parce que au début c'était la
brebis innocentes dans les années 80 au
moment de son mariage et puis après
c'était la femme bafouée celle qu'a pris
le pouvoir parce que diana c'est aussi
l'histoire d'une femme qui prend le
pouvoir c'est vrai travers les médias
puis après c'est le le le drame bien sûr
le tragique et malgré tout ces dernières
années on s'est rendu compte que
vis-à-vis des médias je vais pas dire
que c'était une manipulatrice elle
savait
c'est vrai c'est vrai il faut dire la
vérité avec 25 ans prénom a commencé à
parler on nous dira princesse bling
bling au noga dire que report and
maîtriser totalement la com est-ce que
c'était vraiment sincère quand elle
allait vers les monts d'or du personnel
enfin oui c'est sûr c'était une pro de
la com oui mais en même temps quelle
autre à
qui l'on vous êtes une épouse bafouée
quand vous êtes quand même dans une
famille qui est pas très accueillante 1
très honnêtement
les quatre matins chez la reine donc
quel autre arme c'est là elle a pris
conscience de son incroyable charisme et
elle l'a utilisée ok alors le prince
charles pardon je vais parce que vous
n'avez pas le prince charles 12e fayed
et je sais plus comment s'appelle-t-il
pardon un tas de cannes jeudi à l'époque
jamais tomber amoureux de quelqu'un qui
possède et moins de 150 millions $ comme
m
cc de cavalerie james hewitt kama mx1
bouclera pas d'aplomb
cette relation tout et en même temps
comment lui en vouloir en fait moi je
crois le problème je me sens vraiment
lui en vouloir non mais le déménagement
est normal que tu voyais que ça nous
soyez que dd personnage hyper important
quand vous êtes une tête couronnée vous
pouvez pas comme britney spears
tomber faute et en fait on va toujours
être parfait photo renaître la princesse
parfaite et c'est encore pire avec les
femmes parce qu'en plus quand vous êtes
là une princesse héritière il faut être
juste une mère il faut donner naissance
à l'héritier voilà c'est fini
aujourd'hui elle a montré quatre
princesse dès les années 90 c'était
autre chose et encore heureux qu'elle
ait une vie personnelle elle est
amoureuse
moi j'ai déjà les questions trop
horrible ahmed sont écrites la réaction
écrite par des journalistes qui
travaillent beaucoup de sujets puis je
peux me permettre on en a quand même
produit pas mal il se dit un peu comme à
la que williams et colérique comme sa
mère et que harry basse et non pardon
que williams et colérique comme son père
et que harry c'est un peu le fils de sa
mère c'est à dire que pardon hein que
diana elle était gentil mais
voilà c'était page et nobel quoi c'était
une femme fragile ces voix là c'est s
était pas là une enfance qu'horrible
c'est de me dire qu'elle a vécue surtout
le divorce de ses parents quand ils le
divorce des spencer elle était très
malheureuse je vais faire de la
psychanalyse de comptoir mais elle est
l'aînée l'eau si c'est arrivé pas avoir
un garçon quand vous êtes dans une
famille anglaise noble il faut être un
garçon qu'on méritait de tout juste
avant elle n'est enfin le fils trop me
il meurt au bout de quelques heures
quand sa mère tombée enceinte c'est
encore une fille donc elle pas du tout
attendu n'est pas du tout altérée son
frère charles sera un cadet donc oui
elle était malheureuse était fragile et
certainement harry c'est le plus
puncheur d2 moi j'aime bien savoir
nouveau né dans une famille est ce que
d'autres plus du côté de votre perdu
deux côtés merci forcément c'est
l'héritier c'est le futur on va vous
l'aimez à aller diana les méga la
nouvelle diana oui-oui ou kala cette
rébellion en elle qui fait qu'elle est
la nouvelle diana et elle a aussi une
relation médias qui est particulière
c'est sûr que kate qui est si parfaite
lumineuse un pilier en tout cas de la
monarchie diana était pas impuni on l'a
dit elle est trop fragile pour soutenir
quoi que ce soit si ce n'est elle même
mais j'ai voulu tuer mais rien n'est
parfait
katie dockers et dockers la presse
anglaise se fait parfois le jeu quant à
quant à lady di je me souviens que quand
tu as des morts par dont je ne citerai
pas le nom de l'immense si vous avez un
loto bingo je me souviens toi tout cela
dit on le dit machin est ce que vous
auriez pu ce qui arrive à la princesse
lady di torino et il est le seul c'est
pour ça que plus personne n'en a parlé
après avoir dit à l'époque non parce que
moi je ne devais pas à saint tropez je
ne m'aime pas sur la proue d'un bateau
avec cinquante photographes derrière et
tous documents ce qui arriva lillini ça
n'aurait pas pu m'arriver à moi et tout
le monde était très choquée en misant
mais ce type est tellement humain
comment il peut dire ça sur elle il
avait été agacé en fait justement par sa
part le fait que pendant 20 ans elle a
demandé à des photographes et les a
sollicités qu'un beau jour elle en a une
marge qui peut ce qu'on est absolument
vrai c'est trop tard quand on assiste
alors à rien mais plus rien de moins
c'est très difficile d'être en couple
avec quelqu'un quand tu sais que tu n'es
pas son premier choix elle le savait au
combat la nature sont su qu'elle n'était
pas son premier choix et ses côtés
comporter différemment tigre
royal s est pas les tuer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non pas juste une petite modif sur ce
que sur ce que dit ayem terre qu'elle
n'a pas toujours su dire qu'au départ
elle est
non mais elle l'a su progressivement de
façon horrible
quelqu'un et tu sais faut le dire parce
que tu l'as fait passer pour une fois
que ça pète est vraiment amoureuse de
charme
des amoureux est ce que des mecs plein
aux as elle est tombée amoureuse de son
garde du corps des six mois il ya plus
il ya public américain de richard gardes
du corps donc voilà paraît quelque peu
commun il paraît qu'elle faisait venir
alors je sais pas dans des mallettes ou
likouala carlos ghosn des mecs au palais
pour coucher avec ses allées elles
étaient bien plus ensemble ils étaient
séparés mais la france à bayonne a
toujours vécu au palais de kensington
palace
vous avez l'appartement c'est sûr elle
peut pas faire venir dans une résidence
royale son petit copain comme ça donc
oui il se dit qu'elle était que certains
hommes étaient cachés ou dans le coffre
ou des sous une couverture sur la
rentrée la bbc comme senna mais c'est
incroyable quand même président qui le
font on personnes boya personnes via par
une clique qui arrive à l'elysée on
d'une balise
ah oui aux états unis bien sûr le souci
c'est vrai mathieu que dès qu'une femme
consomment des sommes tout de suite elle
est dans la catégorie croqueuse d'hommes
il sera supervisé un homme tout de suite
merci un gentleman alors j'ai une
question à votre avis est à votre avis
est la reine elizabeth j'espère qu'elle
ne quittera plus tard possible berlin
j'ai beaucoup d'affection pour elle à
votre ami elle en a beaucoup pour vous
mature mais non
à
votre avis laquelle elle déteste le plus
on sait qu'il est d'abord elle n'aimait
pas diana et d'ailleurs il ya
l'enterrement elle a dû parler devant
les anglais presque pour s'excuser
tellement la veille était froide et elle
déteste mais gagnent donc on sait pas on
sait ce qu'on perd on sait pas ce qu'on
trouve laquelle elle déteste le plus je
pense qu'elle ne détestait pas ça na
waie au moins elle avait conscience que
c'était une mère parfaite et elizabeth
ii a beaucoup de qualités mais avec ses
enfants et notamment que le prince
charles elle n'est pas très affectueuse
donc oui je pense que diana était un
moment un poil à gratter ou une épine
dans le pied des mines sera notamment de
la reine je pense que oui mais gagne 8 h
un petit peu sur le système
toutes les familles km sont pas très
cool avec les enfants xm paris 6 et ce
n'est pas les puce mais je crois que des
fois c'est peut-être parce que je vais
vous dire c'est qu'à la mort de la reine
qui tenait tout ça quand ça va être
charles ces deux types qui délaisse
mégane ça va être les carnations aubry
avait alors à bonnart 6